the world of fortnite has given us some
random events to say the least
from an ice king covering the island in
zombie snow and who could forget
a couple of pretty epic concerts
occasionally the seasons we play are
filled with core story which add to
fortnite law
season six of chapter two is one of
those seasons with narrative hidden
everywhere
the seven are back in our lives fortnite
save the world is getting a little more
attention too
and the return of kevin and his minions
look imminent
i'm adam from playstation grenade let's
go through some secret law in season six
and try to predict the future oh and do
me a favor use code adamaru pretty
please
thanks
so that their spire with dwayne inside
good old foundation
when the season began no one was able to
identify the material this structure was
comprised of
well thanks to a fortnight blog post we
have the details for certain
the spires are made from chromium thanks
to the inspired styles for raz
tarana and the spire assassins unlocked
at levels 110 to 150.
i asked google about chromium and i can
almost confidently tell you
chromium is a chemical element on the
periodic table
look it's there it's officially the
fifth hardest metal on earth
well this isn't science class it's the
second style we need to look at
the runic style choice if you paid
attention to razz and tyranna this
season
you'll notice their body markings
tattoo-like appendages all over them
as you know this is the runic language
we all associate with kevin the cube
but surprisingly that's not the only
thing i want to focus on instead it's
the tier 46 item in the battle pass
the endless scroll notice anything here
worth our time
lots of kevin's glyphs are here but look
at this
ring any bells
this looks to be the horns of the storm
king we saw him in battle royale back in
2019
when the central island suddenly became
his domain
it wasn't until later that year we
finally realized the zero point was here
all along
right underneath this exact spot on the
island making many of us re-evaluate the
storm king
and his role in battle royale and if he
was canon to the storyline
now let's go back to the back blink the
endless scroll is reactive
first of all it's damn cool to look at
but this has more to offer
if you know me you know i have a bit of
a thing for japanese culture and
mythology
and if i had to guess i would say this
is a summoning scroll or maybe a chinese
admonition scroll
the thing to note here is this parchment
is different and requires lives to be
offered to empower it
here's how it breaks down as standard
the endless scroll is a black script on
white parchment
after a single elimination offering an
energy pulse activates the runes
and turns them purple at three offerings
the full script is activated with this
blue sheen and glow
and finally after six eliminations a
pink energy erupts
and the scroll is now fully powered
putting all this evidence together we
can surmise that raz
is calling for the storm king to return
to the island and using that force to
increase his own mastery of the glyphs
take a look at the final form of raz
which we will receive
once we complete the spire quests the
same chromatic power flows through
him which he's taken from the spire we
are all expecting the return of kevin
the cube
but could it be kevin's demon of death
who will surprise us all
the backbling requires six elins to
power and i think the six
is important here ever heard of the
number six six
six three sixes in a row is said to be
the number of the beast
a being so evil it wants to obliterate
us all
and i'm pretty sure raz is calling him
back to the island
on the plus side it's another chance to
fight the storm king and claim the
glider you may have missed a few years
ago but it also could be the catalyst
for the return of the cube
this theory goes a little deeper any
save the world players in the house
have you noticed how save the world law
is slowly coming back into the game this
season
kyle has been here for a few seasons now
even though he isn't available in the
store yet
and when he is please use code adamaru
shameless plug thank you very much
but should you play as penny and talk to
kyle there is this
dialogue option to be read kyle remarks
i was just saying we need more
constructors around here
to a br player this means absolutely
nothing
but to someone who plays save the world
you'll know that both these thick
characters
are constructor classes and they have
the ability to reinforce structures
to add to this penny can also speak to
power cord that's where i get my guitar
by the way
in save the world these two are sisters
from england
penny and leanne complete with
overacting vo
leanne come on i'm not going to be cross
with you
it's power chord they are great
right now in battle royale while playing
as penny we can interact with power cord
leanne says you made it to sis
absolutely wicked
in the past we haven't had confirmation
the law carries between save the world
and battle royale
but now we do and that leads me onto the
story of the original storm king
and the first time we met kevin the cube
if you don't want to know anything that
happened in the save the world game mode
switch off now
it's going to get a little spoilery
in 2018 the timeline of save the world
was completely broken
our tiny robot helper rey vanished into
thin air and her existence was alleged
to be in another timeline
this is a good time to remind you that
leakers have told us that a rey skin
is coming to battle royale rey in save
the world is actually a floating bot
named 17 who was made in the image of a
brilliant scientist called desiree
without warning the knight army awoke a
corruption that began to spread across
the land
long story short our heroes attempted to
send a probe through the portals which
the corruption left behind
in order to close the door from the
other side during this mission we saw
penny and power cord reunite
and spoke to dr vindermann you know the
dude who gives us all the v bucks
it was touching finally we battled the
storm king and after a grueling fight
we saw that kevin the cube was the power
behind the storm king
[Music]
i guess that makes you the king of the
monsters commander he slowly dissolved
the way as we came back home
but there was a problem someone needed
to stay behind to set off the bomb to
close the portals
and that person was desiree afterwards
we found this was a failure and the
corruption continued to be seen
the mission ended with a final message
from the v bucks dude dr vindermann
saying commander there is a solution
it is written on the wall since that day
we believe the glyphs
are what we need to understand in save
the world and right now it looks like
kevin is also the key
in battle royale if these two stories
are interconnected with time travel and
portals
then razzy's research and commitment to
the purple runes
is taking us towards an event the
corruption from the spires is spreading
and the locals are becoming restless
barriers are the precursors of war and
the primal age
isn't holding any punches by now i'm
sure you've noticed the formation of the
spires and how it almost perfectly
creates
a cube-like shape the last time we saw
this happen was when kevin the cube
rolled in chapter one the room spots
left behind once again creating a cube
image
he then visited these again as a
floating rock house
happy days we already know kevin's
energy is here in chapter two
through the appearance of the storm king
in 2019 and thanks to kevolution the
steamy stacks this season is plumbing
more smoke than ever before
but the purple water remains dormant it
may only be a suspicion right now but i
believe raz will venture away from the
primal areas and find the remains of
kevin the cube here
a fully glyph mastered razz with the
power of the beast
666 he'd have everything he needs
to summon the cube back but what will
that mean
for the inhabitants of the island i'm
adam from playstation grenade it's been
a pleasure
i'll see you next time all hail the
return of kevin
see ya
[Music]
you